popular anger is growing in zimbabwe
over the failings of the government
inflation is currently above 700
hospital workers are striking
and there's a shortage of food and
medicines in the country
the human rights situation is also
deteriorating
amnesty international says the brutal
assault
on political activists and human rights
defenders who have had the courage
to call out alleged corruption and
demand accountability from their
government
is intensifying now in a moment i'll be
talking to a member of the opposition
but first this report on some
recent developments in the country
this is what it has come to desperate
health workers
pleading with the police in early july
these nurses took to the streets they
are overworked
haven't been paid and don't have
protective equipment against covet 19.
their plight is indicative of the dire
situation zimbabwe finds itself in
it's a society marked by corruption
mismanagement and hyperinflation
now the pandemic has brought a new layer
of suffering on the people
on the 31st of july activists wanted to
demonstrate against the worsening
situation
but some protesters were arrested even
before they took to the street
right police are coming at us and
they're armed
right police are advancing towards us
one of them politician
fatimo here of the opposition mdc
alliance
filmed as riot police moved in streamed
her arrest
live on social media another person
targeted
was the award-winning writer tsetse
dagaremba
she was detained and jailed after
staging her own small protests
she is now out on bail and accuses the
president of holding the people hostage
it's like the people of zimbabwe are in
a choke hold
trying to change zimbabwe for the better
is going to be
a long engagement
and we have to strategize tensions have
been rising in the country in the last
few months
as the economy implodes a defined
president
blames rogue elements and outside forces
the bad apples that have attempted
to divide our people and
we can our systems will be flushed out
despite such threats it's unclear if
monogamous will be able to keep the
upper hand
i'm now joined by mahere in harare she
is the lawyer who was picked up by
wright police in the report we just
aired fazai is also the spokesperson for
zimbabwe's main opposition party the mdc
welcome to dw news africa fadzi you were
arrested last week
what is the status of your case
currently we are we've been released
on bail and we are scheduled to return
to court on the 18th
of september we've got stringent bail
conditions we've handed in our passports
we have to report to the police uh once
a week and we've been ordered not to
interfere with witnesses
all right franzai maybe talk a little
bit about what you've been charged with
but
before you get there just looking from
the outside in there have been a number
of
arrests by the authorities people who've
come out and spoken against
the government are these and your
arrests
part of a wider crackdown and if the
answer to that is yes
why now
they are these arrests are part of a
wider clampdown
as you're aware um you know the
opposition has continuously complained
about the shrinking democratic space in
zimbabwe we've seen a series of
abductions we saw the abduction
torture and sexual assault of the mdc
trio every single day there are reports
of abductions
of you know anti-government critics we
saw the
uh arrest and detention of journalist
hopeworld ching-o-no
we saw the arrest and attention of jacob
ngarivume who's also
a political activist who called for the
planned protest of the 31st of july
a number of journalists like matutu
are on the run currently because of you
know the clampdown by the state
just yesterday the president made a
speech where he
because the government is feeling the
pressure
and yesterday the president said he
wants to flush out opponents he calls
anybody who dares speak about the
national crisis a detr
a detractor a dark force a terrorist
a bad apple the government has no
solution whatsoever to the national
crisis we know that we've got a public
health crisis
a hunger crisis an economic crisis and
they're run
running short of solutions so i think
it's the pressure that they feel because
they've got no answer
and the citizens are have reached their
their wit's end
and they're speaking out and they're
ready to protest and i think
right that pressure that's put the
government in a position where
their only answer is violence
one can appreciate the desperation that
zimbabweans are
experiencing but we are in the midst of
a pandemic
um is it responsible for you as the
opposition to be endorsing mass public
gatherings
and taking part in them as you did
well if you look at the kind of protest
that we did it respected every single
covert regulation that exists
it was socially distanced everybody was
wearing a mask
we're carrying sanitizer and if you look
at the substance of the protest the
cause for it
it's exactly the public health crisis
that we're facing
the corruption that underpinned the
covert 19
supplies it's the very pandemic and the
manner in which it's been mismanaged by
the government that's causing us to
protest
the fact that the public health system
is on its knees
the fact that the government is doing
precious nothing to provide
safety nets for the informal sector
that's hungry in the midst of this
covert 19 pandemic
the fact that the government is doing
nothing to address the concerns of the
striking nurses the striking doctors the
fact that instead of addressing the
public health crisis like other
responsible governments
the government is using this as an
excuse to clamp down
you know and use this uh to to impose a
de facto
a state of emergency that's the only
reason why citizens are protesting so
it's absolutely responsible
for the opposition to protest in the
midst of this global pandemic
the government would be falling short of
our responsibility if we did everything
anything else
granted the government in zimbabwe has
consistently accused the opposition of
being funded by western powers
they say it's to destabilize your
country does your party get any funding
from outside donors
absolutely not i mean we've been running
a consistent campaign where we've been
crowdsourcing from zimbabweans
that's where we get our money from you
know our political party is the mdc
alliance our political power
comes from the people you know we had a
court order which said that the money
from the government grant should have
come to us
that court order was completely
disregarded by the government and
madame coupe and so we've been
crowdsourcing from
zimbabwe and citizens at home and abroad
we're not western funded at all that's a
complete fallacy
um it's a complete untruth we must end
it there that is
propaganda and you know this is no
substance no substance thank you
all right faza maere in harari thank you
you